há uma pergunta que eu escuto com muita
freqüência
vamos ver se vocês descobrem que
pergunta é essa e eu nem sempre gosto de
ouvir essa pergunta não não é sobre a
minha idade
boa parte das pessoas que está aqui hoje
também houve essa pergunta das pessoas
de casa ou daquela vozinha que fala
dentro da nossa cabeça
mas se você está aqui hoje e não escuta
essa pergunta
provavelmente porque você faz essa
pergunta e que pergunta é essa o que tem
pra jantar
o ato de alimentar se
é uma experiência multissensorial que
sacia muito mais do que a nossa fome e
preenche muito mais do que o nosso
estômago memórias de sabores nos levam a
uma viagem ao passado que dura o tempo
exato daquele alimento na nossa boca
alguns anos eu perdi minha mãe e antes
dela nos deixar ela que esteja algumas
coisas organizadas
ela sabia que embora e ela resolveu
organizar o livro de receitas
ela não podia mais escrever mas já
estava e adia escrevia aquelas receitas
que fazem parte do nosso dia a dia e por
isso não estavam registradas e se ontem
eu tive a felicidade o conforto afetivo
do bolo de chocolate da minha infância é
porque minha mãe teve a sabedoria de
deixar receita e eu tenho a sorte de ter
uma filha adolescente que adora cozinhar
e acorda todo domingo inspirada pra isso
se você está nessa sala hoje é um
privilegiado porque você pode pensar
sobre o que você come você pode escolher
aquilo que você come a origem do seu
alimento pode escolher também não pensar
sobre isso pode viver e criar suas
próprias
memórias gustativas e essa aura que
envolve o alimento essa aura mágica elas
vezes desaparece diante de um dia cheio
uma geladeira vazia ea necessidade de
ter que dar mais um pulinho no
supermercado
eu vou falar pra vocês hoje de três
assuntos no primeiro é que não faz mais
o menor sentido a maneira como nós
fazemos compras de supermercado hoje o
segundo é que não faz o menor sentido a
maneira como nós desperdiçamos alimento
e finalmente eu vou falar pra vocês da
minha descoberta como a tecnologia pode
resolver essas duas questões
e aí nós voltamos para a pergunta que a
gente precisa responder 365 dias ao ano
que vem para jantar e eu faço uma lista
e vou ao supermercado a maioria de vocês
deve fazer uma lista também só que
quando a gente chega no supermercado
compro que está na lista e o que não
está na lista
compro saudável porque a nossa
consciência nos manda fazer isso eo não
saudável porque afinal de contas a gente
precisa ter um pouquinho de prazer
a gente compra as promoções porque são
imperdíveis
os produtos premium porque estavam em
degustação
a verdade é que o nosso mais de 7 é
consumista ea gente quer consumir a
gente quer comprar muito a gente não
quer comprar pouco acabou gastando mais
tempo do que eu queria do supermercado
comprando mais gastando muito a
geladeira cheia dá pra muita gente a
sensação de segurança e de sucesso até
profissional eu alcancei algum lugar
alguns pais que sofrem da síndrome do
bom provedor
ela dá a sensação de que a minha missão
foi cumprida
mas tem uma coisa que a geladeira cheia
não faz que é responder a essa pergunta
mas quando ela era cheia fica mais fácil
responder essa pergunta é mais fácil
combinar alimentos e que uma refeição
satisfatória mas os dias vão passando
a geladeira vai esvaziando porque a
gente usa o que estava lá dentro mas
também porque a gente não usa o que
estava lá dentro eu vou dar um exemplo
pra vocês eu comprei um peixe
esqueci no fundo da geladeira em dois
dias
clique aqui para o lixo eu comprei mais
frutas e verduras do que a minha família
consegue consumir e vou ter que jogar no
lixo
alguém abriu o queijo ele ficou lá
esquecido sobre um pouquinho de pão que
passou o prazo de validade
quem é que sabe que a batata prefere
ficar em um ambiente escuro e seco do
que dentro da unidade da geladeira
eu não sabia o desperdício de alimento
ocorre ao longo da cadeia de produção e
consumo nos países em desenvolvimento
ele acontece principalmente no início
dessa cadeia por limitações financeiras
de técnicas de colheita armazenamento e
logística distribuição marketing mas nos
países industrializados
somos nós os consumidores finais e os
varejistas os grandes responsáveis por
um desperdício que poderia ser evitado
um terço de tudo o que é produzido no
mundo é desperdiçado
nós perdemos 20 por cento de todos os
laticínios carnes sementes oleaginosas e
leguminosas
perdemos 30 por cento de todos os
cereais
perdemos 35% de todos os peixes e frutos
do mar e 45% das frutas legumes e
verduras
esses números são muito difíceis de
digerir
e ainda existe uma questão ética porque
mais de 800 milhões de pessoas passam
fome no mundo
o paradoxo do alimento
é que nós morremos pela sua falta mas
também pelo seu excesso
se os números da desnutrição vem caindo
ano após ano os números da obesidade não
param de subir
todos os anos milhares de pessoas morrem
por erros de alimentação e por doenças
relacionadas à obesidade
qual é a mensagem que nós estamos
passando quando desperdiçamos um terço
de todo o alimento qual é a mensagem que
nós estamos passando
quando jogamos alimento fora na nossa
casa nós produzimos alimento hoje
baseados em uma falsa demanda e não no
consumo efetivo e isso precisa mudar
vocês se lembram do que eu joguei aqui
no lixo
eu joguei alimento mas na verdade eu
poderia dizer pra vocês que eu joguei
energia toda energia que foi usada para
produzir esse alimento
eu joguei mão de obra toda a mão de obra
utilizada para produzir esse alimento
nós jogamos fora dinheiro jogando comida
no lixo 750 bilhões de dólares em preços
de produção não de consumo e esse valor
exclui os peixes e os frutos do mar
a gente joga água fora porque só 11% da
água potável utilizada pelo homem vem
pra cidades 19 para indústria e 70% da
agricultura
nós jogamos fora também a terra e tudo
que está sobre ela
o desmatamento para a agricultura e para
a pecuária já é hoje a principal causa
de ameaça à biodiversidade
em outras palavras o que nós temos
jogado no lixo junto com alimentos é o
nosso futuro
não tenho como não citar o jonas salk se
todos os insetos desaparecessem dentro
de 50 anos toda a vida na terra a bainha
mas se todos os seres humanos
desaparecessem da terra dentro de 50
anos todas as formas de vida e irão
florescer é fácil entender por que eu
gostaria de dizer que já falei tudo
sobre desperdício
quando a gente joga alimento no lixo e
ele vai para um aterro ele produz gases
de efeito estufa que influenciam no
aquecimento global
portanto fazer compras como nós fazemos
hoje não faz o menor sentido do ponto de
vista da gestão do nosso tempo da gestão
do nosso dinheiro e do equilíbrio entre
estresse e satisfação jogar alimentos no
lixo não faz também o menor sentido do
ponto de vista ético econômico ou
ambiental e faz menos sentido ainda se
nós tivermos que responder a esse
desafio futuro de alimentar os 9 bilhões
de pessoas previstos para 2050
para isso nós precisaremos produzir 60
por cento mais alimento do que nós
produzimos hoje mas com que recursos
nós vamos fazer isso eu já vinha
buscando uma solução pra organizar
compras e estoque doméstico quando me
deparei com esses números
alguma coisa sem deus dentro de mim
alguns chamam de chamado interno e
encontrou o seu propósito é algo ao qual
eu não posso deixar de responder senão
como diria o poeta eu vou ficar à margem
de mim mesma eu não tenho essa opção de
não fazer alguma coisa e aí eu entrei em
contato com os bancos de alimentos e com
eles eu
descobri o planejamento de refeições o
planejamento de refeições como uma
solução para reduzir o desperdício a
ideia simples você monta um cardápio
semanal
esse cardápio gera uma lista de compras
que inteligente que contempla esse
planejamento e aí você compra só o
necessário mas acontece que eu já tentei
fazer isso antes
eu tentei fazer isso no passado e não
deu certo porque montar um cardápio
baseado em receitas para cada dia da
semana é difícil é complicado mas fazer
a lista de compras baseada nesse
cardápio é ainda mais complicado
sempre dá erro
não tem jeito de você não errar
esse desafio cotidiano individual que é
o que tem hoje para jantar
parece trivial mas ela influencia
diretamente esse desafio coletivo e
futuro que nós temos de alimentar 9
bilhões de pessoas
precisamos fazer esse planejamento e eu
descobri que a única maneira de fazer
isso corretamente é através da
tecnologia e é isso que eu venho fazendo
eu venho me dedicando a colocar de pé
uma plataforma digital para empoderar
qualquer pessoa que cozinha em casa a
planejar brincando as suas refeições
semanais em uma lista de compras
automática e infalível para que você
compre só o necessário para contemplar o
seu planejamento dessa maneira não vai
faltar nada e também não vai sobrar nada
essa é a maneira que eu encontrei para
que nós consumidores finais possamos
fazer a nossa parte
para que nós possamos mandar a mensagem
do que nós realmente estamos consumindo
pra que a agricultura a pecuária ea
indústria de alimentos passem a produzir
baseadas no consumo efetivo com
planejamento
nós conseguimos diminuir todos esses
efeitos que o desperdício em sobre a
economia e do ambiente
eu acredito na força do indivíduo se
juntos nós chegamos a esses números
somente juntos nós podemos mudá los
peço pra vocês escolhem essa idéia do
planejamento de alimentos porque o
futuro ele tem que ser dessa cor
ele tem que ser verde ou ele nem
existirá
vamos começar a planejar agora porque o
maior desperdício de todos é o
desperdício de tempo